guys i got bad news uh-oh uh-oh
what's that spiffy's just closed i don't
even know what it is
that's just news every time this is this
is direct evidence the collapse is here
the country has fallen you know what
else is messed up the dairy so there's
this dairy queen in indiana i used to go
to and they don't have dilly bars there
anymore whoa oh my
god you're telling me that the west
isn't collapsing
check out check out the story uh from
timecast.com diner closed
closes fine uh diner closes find four
hundred thousand dollars for violating
covet 19 rules
uh close wait what diner closes i think
they got a typo in the headline
copy editor guys what are you what are
you doing teamcast.com
uh a diner that was fined four hundred
thousand for violin and covet
has closed permanently the washington
eatery was once referred to as the flash
point for coveted rebellion
by local news outlets they uh
unfortunately they shut down they said
it was due to staffing shortages and
food delivery problems not the fines
so it wasn't the fines interesting okay
but uh i'm sure the fines had to
contribute something to it or they were
just ignoring them
yeah well okay fair enough but uh i i
jokingly say oh spiffy is close it's a
50 year old diner wow in dc
socks 50 years so so look this is just
one example of all the businesses that
we've seen destroyed
because of what's been going on in the
economy and it's fascinating
if you look at civics they're uh they're
they're polling
democrats right now actually think the
economy is good
talk wait how could you genuinely think
the economy is good right now
i'm confused yeah that's unbelievable i
see this article no
now here we are not understanding uh
motivation yeah there you go yeah how
could you think this economy is good it
seems like a human let me see if i can
uh
pull this up and uh i don't i don't
think it's fair to say necessarily that
they're like saying it's the best
right now 36 percent of people in
general
think that the economy is fairly good
but hold on hold on
let's do by democrat only 58
of democrats think the economy is doing
good right now
twenty percent say fairly bad nine
percent unsure seven
seven percent say very good well but
because this is that's the kind of
economy that they want
businesses are shutting down people
aren't able to provide services to the
public they're not able to keep their
door opens but a bunch of people who
aren't working are getting money from
the government
to them that's a good idea hold on i i
think i have an answer to this
if you switch to republican 40 say very
bad
38 say fairly bad and 17 say fairly good
among independent voters 33 percent say
fairly bad
29 percent say very bad and 29 say
fairly good i'll tell you what this is
it's people
who watch cnn yeah yeah yeah you're a
democrat and you're sitting there
watching cnn with drool pouring out of
your mouth like yeah
and they're like everything is great the
economy's recovered and you're like
it's insanity it's insanity meanwhile
republicans are like
my 401k is not doing so well i'm buying
gas i'm out of work right now
like i might be out of work and other
people i know might be out of work but
the economy's doing well because the
media told me it is and you know we're
getting checks from the government right
now and that can last forever
and we're going to keep being locked
down because varian after variant's
going to pop up and they're never gonna
let us go back to our jobs until we get
the seventh and eighth and ninth dose of
the vaccine but no yeah things are great
the economy is doing fine it's on a
rebound a direct
i think it's the result of
the way that the public school teaches
kids zero about economics i mean i
learned about money dimes and nickels in
first grade and i bet i think that was
the last they ever taught me about
economics until college i had to take an
economic success
we had like minor stuff but i didn't
understand like um compound interest
i didn't understand the way that works
that's if you look at the numbers and
you know compound interest you can see
that it's not good we we had we had uh
in second grade they opened up bank
accounts for kids
that's awesome oh awesome we also had we
also had mock
uh presidential elections like great but
i think that might have been a pulling
thing like to see what the kids would
say
and so i i was i remember being a little
kid and they had like one of those old
um dot matrix computers
and then everyone in the line and they
were like pick who you want to be
president i was like rounds perron
oh i'm serious when tim started being a
contrarian but we're gonna put that in a
hit piece
no for real for real i guess i i vaguely
remember this i'm probably getting it
wrong because i was probably like i
don't know how old i was
six or something he's seven and it
because it what they were trying to do
was to see what
what kids would say and it showed what
their parents were thinking
and so you know my parents i think voted
for bill clinton but for some reason i
was like yeah
yeah i tried to get my dad vote for ross
who's like ah i want to go
vote for clinton i don't know vote for
pearl i couldn't get
those ears but um the economy is on fire
yes and uh
we're watching this this controlled
collapse of everything so you so we were
just talking about this
previously but you combine this with
abolition of police defunding of police
you combine this with joe biden define
the supreme court
and just threatening people with jail
for not uh uh you know well
this is a consequence of having a system
where the people who make all of the
decisions
will still have firearms from their
private security when they ban your guns
will still have private security when
they defund the police will still be
getting their paychecks from their
corporate donors when they shut the
economy down and your business gets
destroyed
they face absolutely no consequences for
making decisions that ruin life for the
average american
i think we are in a simulation oh yeah
because they're just
like whoever is running it they're like
uh increase the difficulty
uh are they reacting no increase the
difficulty again
uh did they did they start reacting no
okay crank it up to 12.
how many 12 oh jeez they're still not
doing anything
like it feels like they're just slowly
turning up the knob on the pressure and
people are just like
okay with it like no turn the difficulty
up but tell them the economy is doing
really good and see how many of them
actually believe that well that's part
of the difficulty
i mean it's like propaganda tying
everything everyone's fine but they're
saying things like
staff shortages food shortages gas
shortages
and it's it's it's it's becoming
impossible to to
to run your business dude what a
bungling of this
to give people unemployment that they
will lose if they take their job back in
a lot of countries they would just
companies that had to let people go for
cover the government would pay the
people that they had let go
because they were still working there
and then when they were able to go back
they would just go back to the job they
keep getting paid now by the job again
they're creating an addiction to
government yeah
people if they go back to work they lose
their government paycheck and
government insurance you know it's
unemployment insurance which you get
taxed on for some reason your insurance
payment you're getting the equivalent of
16 bucks an hour not to work
and you're looking at all these jobs and
you're like but even if i take it i lose
this
dude and i'm going to ride this out
those people have to pay taxes on that
unemployment and i don't know if they're
even planning for that i mean how can
you when you're living
paycheck to paycheck yeah you know what
i find remarkable is that we had vosh on
the show just you know uh two days ago
he was in favor he was like i'm in favor
of ubi and i'm like have you not read
the news concern
like you know with respect i'm glad he
came on had a good conversation but i
disagree with him
like have you not read the news or
watched what's going on with be
because we're giving these people money
and you you hear this propaganda
the anti-work on reddit it's like one of
the you know what's funny is like right
it's got a lot of lazy people i'll tell
you this
not reddit they're like we shouldn't
have to work
it's like okay invent replicators and i
got no problem with that
like you can sit around and just say
earl grey hot and then you're not gonna
work but everything else requires work
because of i don't know the second law
of thermodynamics
but anyway we're in ubi this is
it i i said this i remember i was i was
hanging out when i was on joe rogan he
asked me like what do you think about
ubi and i i was like
i think people wouldn't want to work and
then you get these left as saying like
oh that's not true
actually you know you know my favorite
question is like uh ian i mean no no
i'm sorry sheamus yes
[Laughter]
how many people do you know playing for
this one how many what how many people
do you know play the guitar
play the guitar oh man that's a good
question i went to an art school tim so
you're looking at a disproportionate
sample here
just but probably like let's say i know
five people who play guitar and uh how
many of them are bad at guitar
oh man i don't know i don't ask my
friends to play for me
i'm just like i'm sure you're great like
here's the thing the only people i know
who play guitar are people i know who
play because like i've been in their
shows and stuff so they're decent
they're good so i'm sure i know plenty
of people who are bad at guitar
most people know like everybody plays
some kind of instrument to some degree
not everybody but like a lot of people
and so most most people will be like oh
i know a few people who play the guitar
and how many are bad i know a few of
them are pretty bad do you think the
people who are bad
would stop working and try to become
famous musicians
oh i could see it happening yeah i when
they're younger yeah
i grew up in chicago i knew tons of
people who had well-off parents
yeah who are like i'm going to make
music and i'm like bro you're not good
at this
like you just you're not going to be a
celebrity doing this and that's the
thing about
ubi you give someone money
and to not produce so here's what
basically what it basically means you're
giving someone money which is access to
extract from the system
yes and then instead of putting anything
meaningful back in
they make bad music yeah exactly well so
this is interesting because
it you can take it a step further a lot
of people want to have
you know youtube channel or twitch
channel they want to find some way to
make money with social media
and when you're starting you can hit a
point where you know maybe you're able
to make a couple hundred dollars a month
that doesn't necessarily
mean you're cut out for the industry
that doesn't mean this is going to be
something that'll turn into a full-time
career
but that ubi plus a couple hundred
dollars a month from whatever you're
doing on social media could push you
over the edge and actually be enough for
you to live off of
so it gives you an unrealistic idea of
what your prospects are and social media
is one example
but there are all sorts of arenas where
you might be able to make a little bit
of money
and that combined with the stipend
you're getting from the government could
be enough to live off of but that's not
where your
labor is most productively used by the
majority of people
giving to and receiving from the economy
so you're actually
doing a net disservice to the country
overall exactly right so so my view of
this is like okay here's
here's an option easy access to grants
for young people
you turn 18 you can now go to the local
grant center which is very easy to go to
you know present your little pamphlet
and be like here's what i want to do and
then request a certain amount of money
to engage in that project because one of
the issues that i hear a lot
from the ubi crowd is think about all
the talented people
who are stuck working a crappy job
because if they quit they'd lose their
apartment they'd be homeless
and i'm like that's true there are a lot
of young people of great talent i know
i know growing up people who are
insanely good at skateboarding and i was
like man these guys got to go pro
sorry they didn't have the sponsors they
didn't have the means to film and they
had to work otherwise they'd lose their
job and
or they'd lose their apartment and i was
like if this guy was just given
a little bit of money so he could skate
we'd have great another great pro
so how about instead of the worst of
both worlds we do the best of both
worlds you got to work to pay your bills
and at a certain age you can say like
here's what here's my plan i'm a young
person and then get a grant
and that's it that's your chance it's
complicated though because you have to
ask the question even if there are many
talented people in a particular field
who don't have an
opportunity to try to enter it you have
to ask how many
people with that particular talent can
the economy support so let's say
everyone who's good at skateboarding is
able to get this grant where they can
become a professional skateboarder i
mean realistically how many professional
skateboarders can our economy
support you know i don't think we're not
we're not offering them
we're not offering an infinite or
indefinite amount of money it's
here's a grant to run your business and
they have to have a plan they come to
you with a plan saying i would like a
grant for this particular project
for sure i thought so it sounded to me
like the point that you were making was
we'll tap into all sorts of talent we
haven't gotten before but my concern is
we'll give a lot of money to people and
they'll end up with a lot of debt and
they're not really going to end up
controlling they end up in debt
well because they don't end up
successfully taking oh a grant i'm sorry
okay yeah and i'm not talking about a
hundred grand i'm talking about a few
thousand dollars yeah yeah so it's like
they can take less
they can invest some money into
something basically saying like can we
invest in young people
instead of indebting young people and
putting them in colleges that just grind
them to
the to dirt yeah well one of the weird
things is i'm not entirely sure how i
feel about a grant but it is very
strange that almo you know any young
person can go get a loan to go off to
college even if the degree isn't going
to pay off for them and it's obvious
based on the degree they're choosing but
if you go in with a really solid
business plan
at 18 the likelihood that you're going
to get a loan is extremely low that's
insane
that's totally backwards yeah i would
agree right right right but but
and so part of the reason that we have
the tuition crisis that we have in the
student debt crisis is because
this is not just my personal opinion i
think this is something that's borne out
by all the most basic rules of economics
and if you need a citation the national
bureau for economic research has said
this is the case but
colleges respond to an increase in the
availability of student loans
by increasing tuition costs i mean so
now we have absurdly expensive college
costs
because the government came in and said
hey let's help people go to college well
it turns out all they did was make it
more difficult for people to go and i
don't know
if it was necessarily a plan on their
part i don't think it was i just think
they
screw up whenever they try to help and
then you i mean college is basically
indentured servitude
it's you here's the money for your
opportunity and then you got to pay it
back and then most people can't and they
get mad and they demand communism and
then i got to pay the bill for it
this thing well i think what's even more
insidious is many of them
can pay it back i think even a majority
but the problem is
the people who can pay it back i mean
look there is an economic hierarchy in
terms of who is able to be accepted into
college in the first place so
if you grew up in a rough neighborhood
where you weren't able to get the kind
of education that someone who went to a
decent private school or a good public
a decent public school as far as public
schools go and the suburbs
went to you're going to be less likely
to get into school right so when we
forgive
student debt oftentimes what it does is
it redistributes wealth
from working people who never had the
opportunity to go to college
and towards people who started out in
the upper class and then went to college
who
are no longer being expected to pay off
the debts which they voluntarily
encourage so this is what i
actually responded to a leftist with
this and i i was on twitter
i thought i was gonna get just like all
these leftists screaming at me because
they're like
somebody said something like that they
said uh it was a tweet about
you know when you say we shouldn't pay
back someone's you know forgive student
debt because you had to pay it off
you're basically saying they should
suffer because you did no
and my response was i just don't think
it's right to make working-class people
pay off the debt exactly
of the highest income earners in the
country exactly and people actually
that's a good point yeah
college degree people with college
degrees earn higher salaries on average
than people without them why should
working class people pay off the debts
of the highest income earners
we are funneling money to the top tier
no way dude do do the inverse how about
we make the college students with their
high incomes pay their fair share
pay your fair share well i mean often
those people end up going into the one
percent and paying an absorbent amount
in taxes but
the one percent does not it's still yeah
or top 10 well again well
even the top 10 percent i mean the
higher how about income earners pay
the majority how about these people who
took out student loans pay
their fair share yes they got free money
yeah and now they want working poor
people the proletariat
to pay their bills no it's actually true
your fair share college
debt holders should define them it's
actually true bernie sanders is a
buzzword
i'll tell you what fair share is fair
share is and to be fair i'm not talking
about exorbitant interest rates that
campaign yeah yeah i think that's crazy
i think that interest is unfair
yes i agree we're compound because my
stance has always been
we can we can stop the interest rates
and say
pay back your remaining principle that's
your fair share
but when they what they're saying right
now is joe biden could snap his fingers
and erase all federal debt
for for college students why doesn't he
do it because that would be you
not paying your fair share diluting the
economy and it would be an invisible tax
on the working class
so you got free money you have to spend
it you pay your fair share
now hold on i agree with you the the the
the interest rates are insane
wrong and broken 100 that we get rid of
yeah yeah no i mean
it's insane that you could charge
interest on a loan that's guaranteed i
understand some small amount to hedge
against inflation but the idea right
people
like one percent over the lifetime of
something or you know you know something
adequate to um
something adequate to offset the value
that will be lost through inflation
but not so much that you're able to
profit off the idea of like profiting
off of a gear or even just
like uh if if you take out 10 grand you
owe an extra hundred dollars
like look if we're trying to uh
invest in young young people to be
better able and better capable
then i think we can give out straight
loans with
you know with inflationary interest but
at a certain point
you should be able to pay back just the
principal the
the interest rates are insane they
compound it gets higher i hear too many
stories from people who are like i took
out forty thousand dollars and now i own
it
now i owe eighty and it's like that's
that's completely insane right that's
completely insane
it shouldn't it shouldn't i think if you
like you're out of work it should just
stop
like i don't know man the system's
broken and i'll tell you this before we
even get any of that stuff i'm like we
need to re
i'm totally you know what i'll tell you
this here's my compromise i
i will personally accept a greater
amount of of debt to be erased outside
of interest if it also means
we either seize the endowments from the
universities or
and i don't i mean that half jokingly or
we we outright end
the college loan debt pipeline that
whole thing has to stop
well i mean no they absolutely have to
stop federally guaranteeing student
loans that's the only way
it comes back well let me actually be
clear there's going to be a bubble at
some point right at some
i mean the bubble's going to pop at some
point i should say we're already in a
bubble this can't sustain itself forever
but it's just clear that eventually
they're going to have to stop federally
subsidizing these loans and certainly
making the problem worse that they do
subsidize them so they have to stop
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time